hello everyone and welcome to a really
really wild game from the final round of
the vhs olympiad we are going to show
one more game uh and then we are going
to discuss the standings as we still
haven't shown that uh it is gabriel
sergion versus alexey shirov board one
of armenia and board one of spain both
of them uh almost well sargisian almost
2700 before the start of the event and
alexis shiro a 2700 member uh it is uh
it's well it's a game you would expect
to see when alexa shiro is playing and
well yeah he is also another master of
the mystic arts uh so it's no wonder
that
such a game happens the game is over
extremely quickly uh so don't be
surprised by that uh so let's check it
out sergey sean has the white pieces and
he opens with d4 and before we check out
the game uh here is a very nice photo of
the handshake between the two of them
you can see that shiro is very happy to
start playing uh
still no eye contact but we we have yet
to see eye contact between chess players
before the start of the game and i think
the s on his shirt is really really
awesome it's probably a logo from some
company but it could also stand for you
know just shirov and
it's tilted 90 degrees sort of
representing his extremely wild style of
play but it's it is most likely a logo
of a company uh but okay sergey sean
opens with d4 we have d5 by alexa c4 and
c6 going for the slav defense knight f3
knight to f6 and queen to b3 uh very
standard stop putting pressure on the
center and then the b7 pawn uh
preventing the light square bishop uh
from being developed the captures on c4
black forces wide to waste the tempo
queen captures and bishop to g for now
we have knight to c3 and not knight b to
d7 uh and here uh e4 is a very standard
idea but first we have bishop to f4 and
now bishop captures on f3 we have g
captures and now white's pawn structure
is a little bit messed up but he will
play e4 at some point and he will have a
massive center here so knight b6 attacks
the queen queen d3 and now knight f to
d5 again all very very standard played
many many times knight captures knight
captures and now as the bishop is
attacked bishop back to d2 preparing e4
to dislodge the knight from this mighty
d5 square so e6 uh and now pawn to e4
and here there are some games where
knight f6 was played also knight to b
for going after the queen is a known
move but here we have queen uh knights
to c7 uh by shirob and it is not as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game so here sergian castles queen side
and now queen to h4 leave it up to
alexei to bring his queen into the game
early he attacks the f2 pawn and also
the queen can be shifted to h5 to go
after the f3 pawn as those are the two
weaknesses in white's camp so bishop e3
defends the pawn here and now shoot of
castles queen side we have queen to d2
now preparing bishop to g5 and this is
where the game really starts to
uh bring smiles to everyone's faces uh
shirov plays g6 and it's a move that
only shiro would play it's such a it's
such a brilliant move uh but the problem
is it loses the game but if it weren't
for that a very particular line that
wins for white it's actually a really
really classy idea first you have to
play queen to h5 go after the f3 pawn
the game just continues and nothing
special is happening here however after
g g6 sort of daring uh sergey sienta
play bishop to g5
the game is completely lost for shiro
but not for the reasons that you think
or maybe you think them so then you are
also as strong as sergian
so bishop to g5 was played attacking the
queen and the rook and now queen to h5
and here what do you play it's a very
tricky position feel free to pause the
video and play the move that shiro
missed and sergey sian found while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well sort of a silent tricky move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is bishop to e2 this is the
move that wins the game and while we are
going to discuss why i know you guys are
wondering what happens if we just grab
the rook well bishop to h6 and now white
has some problems here there there
aren't the great problems but they are
very annoying you have to play f4 here
now we captured the bishop here and the
white is of the exchange but black has
uh
well sufficient compensation here it's
definitely a position shiro would
happily play so instead after queen h5
bishop to e2 was played and now
what do you play here problem is your
rook is still hanging let's say you try
and save the rook h4 comes and now your
queen cannot move f4 will be played on
the next move and you will uh you will
have lost your queen so another thing
you could do after this bishop to e2
idea is play queen to h3 this is also
possible but now rook d to g1 preparing
rook to g3 and after bishop to d6
guarding this square we just play f4 and
there is no good way of preventing rook
to g3 you can play f6 uh hope to
you know get the queen back into the
game if the bishop captures maybe you
can retreat via queen to h6 uh but they
just rook to g3 and now okay you will
get two pieces for uh the queen but it
is uh
it is definitely not enough captures
captures and white will be completely
winning so that's the problem after
bishop to e2 so sheriff tries bishop to
b4 he attacks the white queen hopes for
bishop queen captures bishop so he can
capture the bishop and g5 with check but
gabriel just plays queen to e3 he's not
interested in in the bishop he just
wants to play uh this and captured or
rather h4 and then f4 and trap the black
queen so here uh
e5 again if you move the rook you know
what is coming so here shiro shows why
he is such a uh such a great player he
plays e5 and this uh directly stops f4
because if you play f4 now now e
captures on f4 also attacks the white
queen white will still be much better
here most likely even winning but of
course euro will get some counter
chances so instead after e5 we have
bishop capture 78 sergiyan says all
right i will take the material rook
captures on d8 and not just d captures
on e5 uh leaving black without uh
well
without any compensation whatsoever so
queen captures on e5 rook captures on
the e8 trading off now material because
if you are up in material you want to
trade down rook to d1 with check king to
e7 and now pawn to f4 uh we have queen
to c5 with check shiro now tries a queen
trade because he might survive the end
game but it is uh well it is it would be
silly to expect to survive such an end
game so here king to b1 uh queen
captures on e3 f captures and not knight
to e8 and of course the game is
completely winning now now it's only a
matter of how sergician will convert to
this so here pawn the e5 bishop to c5
goes after the pawn and now bishop to g4
trying to get that rook to d7 check in
so pawn to f5 and now he captures an f6
with check up a song
knight captures and bishop back to f3
and of course this cannot be captured
because rook t1 is just very very
annoying
so instead we have h6 and now pawn to h4
we have king the e6 now comes king to c2
and ponte h5 uh shirt of trying his best
to keep everything at bay but uh i mean
it is simply unplayable but bishop to e7
we have rook to g1 going after the pawn
here king f7 and king to e2 now we have
knight to d7 bishop to e4 and now knight
to f8 we have rook to h1 and not knight
back to d7 he has to wait and see how
sergian will push this so bishop to c2
we have bishop to f6 going for the pawn
here and now pawn to e4 saying that if
you capture here i'm just gonna play
rook to b1 and then your queen side
falls apart as well so here bishop to d4
now comes pawn to e5 uh really limiting
the movements of this of this bishop
knights to f8 and now king to d3 we have
upon the c5 defending the bishop king to
e4 b6 now and pawn to b4 of course
this is impossible uh the bishop would
hang so king to e7 and now bishop to b3
are taking all of these squares away
from the black king bishop to f2 putting
pressure on the h4 pawn if the rook ever
moves but you don't have to
worry about that quanta b5 uh knights
the d7 and now bishop to c4 just putting
pieces on optimal squares before you go
for that final piece of infiltration
knight to f8 we have rook to h3 and now
bishop to e1
and finally pawn to f5
g captures king captures knight to d7
and now rook to a3 and he was in this
position on mu 49 that alex hero
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here rook captures on a7
is coming and that's it a game might
continue with something like bishop
captures on h4
but then just rook captures on a7 now
you're threatening e6 to pick up the
knight and if you move the king now you
just play king to e6 and there are no
moves here uh
whatever you play doesn't really matter
uh if you go here then we just attack
the knight you lose the knight if you go
knights to f8 with check we just play
king to d6 we push the pawn win the game
uh
absolutely everything is winning here so
really tough break uh for for shirov he
really tried to play aggressive he tried
to play uh creatively he tried to play
in his style uh but after this um uh
queen to h5 move uh he thought bishop
captured 78 was coming but he completely
overlooked the ship to e2 sergey sian
found it and hopefully uh some of you
found it as well
now uh here is uh something that i
wanted to show you uh before we uh
before we end the video uh this is a
congratulations from levon arunan as you
know he is now playing for the united
states he is no longer playing for
armenia he says incredible performances
by the by young uzbekistan india too but
for me especially armenia uh winning
silver and coming so close to gold is
incredible and makes me very proud i
hope such a sensational performance will
get a deserved recognition and i thought
that for some reason levon skipped
their their brawl with armenia when the
united states was playing against
armenia but levon later explained that
he caught some allergies and that he was
unable to play for for the last few days
and that he is still recovering in in
case some of you were wondering about
that and also here are the final
standings of the olympiad uh or rather
of the open olympiad as there is also
the women's section uh
team uzbekistan wins the event uh tied
with armenia as you can see both of them
with 19 match points but uh
uzbekistan has more board points as
players individually performed better
than armenians
with 33 board points i don't know if
it's actually board point i always
thought it was board points maybe it's
something else but yeah 33 board points
versus 28 and a half more points then we
have in third place with 18 points india
two the youngsters uh grabbed
the the bronze medal in the olympiad uh
the main team of india grabs fourth
place which is incredible of course you
that is i mean an incredible result but
you are that close to getting the metal
so i mean it's uh
uh
not what they wanted especially since it
was organized in india i imagine it um
would mean a whole lot to them if they
won the medal but at least one of their
their teams won it
moldova also incredible result uh also
17 points united states of america the
top seed everyone expected them to to
fight for first place and they did fight
but uh in the end only sixth place then
with 16 points hungary and azerbaijan
also poland and lithuania with 15 points
we have netherlands spain montenegro
greece england france uh israel
kazakhstan brazil and cuba uh so those
are the the top 20 uh countries in the
uh vhs olympia 2022. uh so yeah that's
the game a little bit of photos a little
bit of final standings i hope you guys
enjoyed that uh so it always brings a
smile to my face when we see a game by
alexa shiro because you never know what
to expect uh and here uh i mean no one
knew what to expect sergey sian didn't
know what to expect in india and shiro
didn't know what to expect out of that
uh
uh
brilliant move that loses the game
uh so yeah once again really hope you
guys enjoyed this if you have any
favorite games uh from the women's
olympiad do use hashtag suggestion and i
will go over them as we will show a
couple of games so uh make sure uh you
you choose well uh i would like to thank
michael calber sununu chandra khan
madhukar chess connects us uh ki sink
and kathleen althea cash man for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad as like i said we are going to
check out a few more games so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day